[Music]
okay listen welcome back to frenemies
sponsored by adam and eve we just we're
doing a pizza eating competition
we were what 10 minutes in the computer
crashed
trisha was ahead by one slice and now
she's whining
like a baby that she can't continue this
competition because
it's been sitting and i'm crushing it
okay then
keep eating but what happened you were
crushing [ __ ] explain
we have a 30 minute time frame to see
who can eat the most pizza
i don't feel full until 30 minutes after
i start eating
now i'm feeling full but had we just
done a full 30 minutes i could have
eaten all three boxes
by myself guaranteed we can do it next
week whatever but it was one it was like
already cold starting
two i was way ahead of you i was crying
you were watching myself
ahead of me i was in my zone the footage
got corrupted i was still
hungry that's what you don't understand
you're sitting here whining about having
ate for like five and a half slices
i'm still hungry i crushed you so hard
and you were hit by one slightly
eight minutes in how i was eating that
pizza was a technique and i was crushing
it
where's 20 minutes on the clock no and i
was crushing it
and now you won't nobody will get to
even see that footage and you're like
let's start over now and i was like no
because now i'm out of the zone and now
i'm full i drank water we had a break
pizza's been sitting for 30 minutes like
dude you can't let me have anything
i'll let you have the pizza and who's
going to win
dude if she's already saying she's full
i mean i can't read the future i don't
if you if you're
just saying you're was i not like
dunking on ethan during the pizza eating
competition dogging
we were only eight minutes in however i
mean she was in the lead thank you
buy a whole slice like that i was
crushing it you're already full i
i'm hungry do you understand what the
monster you're up against
i'm fine so you want to keep eating or
what
yes fresh boxes then i can't i can't
okay let me finish this one no
why just that's just for fairness to you
trying to be fair to you
no because you still have another size
i'm one i'm i'm one of the left sides i
got
i want credit for you often i have only
one left wait i'm getting credit for
this slice
so you have to eat another one to match
me okay okay okay
why don't we heat those up are you on
let's go
i don't want to heat it up because it
makes it crunchy so now you got to eat
another one to be even with me i'll
finish this one and i guess we can do it
forever
okay thank you okay thank you for
because look
it's just not okay you know i feel like
i was gonna finally win something oh no
do cold pizza is life has everything
um still loving it
i don't know ethan even if you win it
she's not gonna give it to you because
of all of these
extraneous facts no i'm like ethan i'm
not a sore loser
i give the competition
you on the other hand argue even
saturday
when you came to my house you were still
arguing that matt
demarco was just [ __ ] with you and
that's why i won the cop cooking
competition
you're like moses you know and i was
like no you didn't burn the steak you
were still arguing about what my god
in private
it's not that serious it's
literally that serious to you and we've
been drinking water and now i feel full
drinking water you blowing
it expands in your stomach
and we were talking all right mom
anyways we're
we're talking about you but i guess that
story is done okay no
i gotta restart it you're gonna restart
it
you also wanted to like do the podcast
tomorrow like the vibes off i'm like
because we couldn't do a pizza eating
honey
i said that for you it wasn't all the
vibes are off for me
no the pizza vibes because you were like
cause you're sitting here like pizza
vibes are back on
you're like i can't eat cold pizza i
don't want to put it in the oven though
because it will get crispy i was like
okay goldilocks let's do it tomorrow
i'm goldilocks are you a bear you're
like you're a teddy bear you're like too
hot too cold i was like the porch you're
just trying to be
oh i get you thank you i thought you
were like my little bear
two little bears one two three okay
we're eating now you're the third one
okay
i'm really sad too because um thank you
thank you so we're both at five slices
but i was eating faster than you so what
are we putting
yeah it was a 30 minute competition
competition
i know but you're already full and it's
like well yeah
but i'll continue so so what you want to
put like 20 minutes on the clock 15
12 because we've already done the
18-minute sitting period
okay whatever you want awesome 12
minutes
15 i guess it's good
oh you already started okay cheater such
a cheater
and it's a speed competition you're like
just eating pizza what do i do you
literally do this just so you can eat
and you can just
like oh it's for a friend of me that's
for work this was your idea
you put me at the scapegoat so you can
cheat on your meal plan
this was your guys's idea i didn't want
to do this you're gaslighting me you're
pizza gas lighting name
i'm sorry i apologize and literally i've
been on a diet
i've been eating less food so i'm at a
deficit you said you've been eating
pizza every night you've been training
you're like
they miss all those gems when are
competing i know it's not fair i shared
a fun memory of us eating orange chicken
and that's all i could think about is
that
i know and now we're fighting before it
was like all good vibes and energy and
now we're fighting if the
vibes are still good i've got the
scoreboard okay we're at five five
oh getting low we're gonna start at five
yeah yeah
okay
okay trish is in the mood now i don't
know what the [ __ ] because these are the
vibes
and i'm trying so hard
what i'm not busy i have [ __ ] to do too
but yours is in the basement you come
down to the basement record i have to
get glam i have to come to your house i
have it's like a whole thing
well you just come downstairs in your
teddy fresh shorts and that's it
it's your daily life and i love it and
that's good you're killing it but
all right you want to put up or shut up
at this point yeah i'm ready are we
ready
dan are we ready i mean what's the deal
with the fight but we're ready all right
okay i mean
all right all right here we go three two
here i'll let you take a bite
okay all right you take two of those
three fights
here eat the whole slice the time
doesn't matter to me it's literally
about time
no it's not what's it about there's
enough time i'm saying
oh trigger warning fast forward 12
minutes ahead if you don't like food and
talking
because there's a lot of there's going
to be them there's going to be good
stories though
but you have to hear the chewing and the
noise but some people maybe okay
so i was telling the story about
oh my god you look a little chipmunk
because i gotta win now
i'm so annoying i've been saying here
with pizza i'm in my mind so competitive
i have to win i can't eat cold pizza i
can't eat it's too crispy out of the
oven
what the digestion thing is tastes worse
though you're right
the crust is like super [ __ ] soggy
it's not soggy um
so
what's your second name what's your like
super technique taking tons of bites
fast well
it tricks my body
so the fbi came to my house
on friday morning i'm telling the story
for the second time
not swatting no fbi agent
he said is that acceptable yeah thank
you
honor among the competitors
so fbi comes smiles oh my god
tell me who's competitive dude i'm not
even in a hurry because like
i'll go i'll go slice on slides but i
have to i'm still hungry that's what you
don't understand
you never understand i'm hungry
watch watch the level i'm at that's two
slices on top of each other oh man
oh my god now you're flexing i know
like give me something but pizza's
already been sitting in my belly for 20
minutes
look i just don't think you've ever had
a chance
you see one time are you exciting me out
you are now you're doing two slices of
my one
um and i'm liking it too i'm not even
i'm a little full just a little bit
i have a smaller stomach than you though
this is like facts because i have
liposuction
well i was i really thought you know
going into this competition i was like i
always under
underestimate trisha i've been dieting
but like is this really a competition
you want to win necessarily either you
know what i mean yeah i want to win
every competition
i have you just cheat on the other ones
you have beat me and everyone except the
science one
the science that was also fake that was
also rigged
how was that rigged that one ballot so
they thought we were picking
two out of the four categories and we're
doing all four
so fbi comes in friday morning and they
said
8 30 am ring my doorbell
look at you
and he says we have threats that
somebody's sending a bomb to your house
i was like what fbi agent with the badge
and everything shows up with the guard
8 30. does we have to reject all
packages
he says have you guys got any packages
today that you brought into the house
and open
he's like we have to reject all packages
until we can figure out
the source of the threat and was it on
like reddit like where did they see the
threat
he didn't so what the what happened was
he was just the closest agent
so they sent him to our house to warn us
like as soon as possible so he didn't
have all the details
so but what i think happened was that
they must have seen it on some like
neo-nazi forum because like the fbi is
monitoring
all this white nationalist terrorism
group since um
was it march 6 the was that the day
oh january pretty close
since they stormed the capitol and so
he just stared at me with a mouthful of
pizza i hope are you intimidated by this
yeah i'm getting nauseous but i want to
hear the story um
you remember the first time we met you
said to me i am so you remember how
impressed you were about how i was
casually throwing slices yeah um
yeah i'm the real deal but i would have
been you had we done it right with
popcorn i'm just saying i'm the real
deal i want you to
acknowledge that i'm the real deal can
you finish the fbi story i like the
story
okay and then you talked about
daddy on storage worse infowars
he's hot right he's such a mess what are
we talking about the leftists are coming
for you because you you talked about
aunt being an anti-vaxxer
okay so trisha did that um
i only got vaccine for you you did well
i don't think that's the only reason i
shouldn't say that
i don't know actually you think you
scheduled my appointment for me like
your assistant was like
you're like here she's scheduling for
you today i was like ah okay
i mean i should well you know i'm blind
wait i didn't force you into it
it was a hard nudge we said do you guys
want
help getting the appointment we did that
for all of our employees um
dope i'm glad we signed up and anyone
who wanted we made it easy for them to
get
anyways so you said everyone needs to be
vaccinated these people were like [ __ ]
ethan
on twitter so on twitter there was like
a whole debate there was all these
bomb on the air you can say bomb really
don't say like i'm gonna bomb
this place the fbi tracks you now
hopefully not um how much time we got on
the oh we still got eight minutes i
guess i should focus on eating but
i'm not worried i'm gonna grow up
you are okay wait so the fbi shows up my
stop house just watching you eat a
psychologically like tormenting meme
[Music]
i love eating with you i don't like
watching you eat
this is the worst because we look
we lost the first part of the story
fbi shows up
and they say i think it's related to
this tweet i made about
people were tweeting about no vaccine
passport
all these conservatives were saying it's
like uh fascism and all this [ __ ]
don't even know what that means fascism
no they don't either apparently
sounds like fat shaming fascism is like
uh
you know world war ii like the nazis
were fascists it's like what does that
mean total government control
of every of everything and propaganda
and uh like ultra-nationalism and stuff
like that
and you're anti-fascist oh yeah
definitely anti-fascist
as any sane person should be i think um
anyway they were saying that passport
vaccines like fascism and all this and i
was like you guys are [ __ ] idiots
like
we can't go to a crowded venue without
proving that the people that are
vaccinated otherwise you're going to
turn into a super spreader event
people there who aren't vaccinated can
continue to spread the virus the virus
is going to continue to mutate and to
the point where it's
resistant to the vaccine and and you
know we can eradicate this [ __ ] virus
of all these idiots were just
uh stopping douches is basically what i
said
yeah so people were really like that so
like infowars made a whole reaction to
my tweet
[ __ ] full wars who are they yeah i
literally don't know who they are you
were saying you don't know who alex
jones is
no you think he's daddy though i think
he's daddy
pull up a picture of him i saw a picture
of our video of alex jones damn recently
where he was like
at the border and he waddles is he fat
yeah well i don't know him
he's husky but he's got a waddle for
this i waddle for sure too
nothing wrong with a little duck
quacking i'm starting to waddle i love a
bottle
it's because my thighs um rub so i have
to waddle a little bit
oh you do yeah i gotta avoid that jump
rub oh my god
well i better focus on your ears
i hate that what the [ __ ] rubbing i
like it
you like your thighs no i like the i
like the friction it causes like i like
seeing the little red dots in between
someone's eyes
really mm-hmm for me it's just because i
maybe because i have hair there it's
just really just like
grinding like it's kind of wet mm-hmm
baby powder i've tried that nothing
works
harder though i've tried it before it
doesn't work
not really you put on your balls i'll
say that yeah
how's that work well
seven oh my god you're true
wait oh we both equal them mm-hmm
what i've been too confident
man holy [ __ ]
clean um
um
you're worthy competitor about i don't
think you're going to take it but you're
you're doing
after everything that happened you're
putting on a good showing
it doesn't bother me i mean it's
disgusting but it doesn't bother me
it's really gross
man this is too fatty [ __ ] right here oh
my god
you have so much pizza in your mouth
[ __ ] i can't let you win now because now
you're actually pulling up on me
you're about you're a valiant competitor
there's no way i can squirt after
this you have to go for it you have to
do a squirting video yeah now though
you're going to squirt marinara sauce
oh my god
i can't are you done
are you stepping out oh my god
so anyway um
alex jones made a whole segment or not
alex jones but infowars made a whole
segment about
i'm like a fascist libtard maybe they
said
you're a fat [ __ ] a fat [ __ ] maybe
maybe you've inserted it i've been
getting fat streamed a lot recently it
doesn't bother me but you've been
getting fashion recently
no no i've seen on the twitter people
like about this
this um this podcast the vaccine [ __ ]
like all the hate i've been getting
a lot of it's like oh you're fat yeah
that's me too that's like the one thing
they can go for i never got that before
it doesn't bother me i was just
surprised i didn't bother me there i've
heard my whole life i thought while i'm
fat cool
[ __ ] that was rushing my brain what
did they say about him i'm sure daddy
jones is fat
daddy jones is very thick good point
okay thick daddy so do we only listen to
skinny people what's your argument
yeah there's been a lot of fat legends
oh
oprah you call oprah fat i agree well
she says it she goes on diets all the
time
she's always eating that caller you're
the rosie o'donnell on youtube oh my god
wait is that the girl who was canceled
for sick using like
no brother someone else
rosie o'donnell called trump a pig oh no
trump called her a pig
dude you gotta slow down on your kind of
stressing me out
so anyway all these conservatives were
angry at me so who's in the bomb
so i think it was connected to this
because the fbi
is monitoring all these like white
national terrorists and so it must have
popped up on like a neo-nazi forum
are we left on this podcast are we
left-wing
i am i mean that might i don't know
where you are
do i have to be right because i'm on the
right side of you can do whatever you
want
i think we should be like the view i
should be one of those blond [ __ ]
that are always republican you
definitely seem
to be socially very very liberal
you're you're cnn i'm fox news i don't
think you're [ __ ] smooth
i'm too fat i never have a face i think
you like gay and trans people too much
to be fox news
they don't no no support they'll know
um why anderson cooper he's gay i know
some bloopers on cnn um
i always thought he was right all right
he's white
oh whoa who's the girl on fox news
that's not hot
greta greta van susteren how come she
gets to be on there but everyone else
has to be hot and perfect oh my god
anyway i could be greta i guess
no okay i'm gonna double it okay wait
one minute flop oh my god slow down bro
oh my god are you the one that you
already had
i don't like this hard to get it down
mm-hmm
oh [ __ ] 30 seconds
oh my god wait you should
you're harming yourself by alternating
you have 20 seconds
[Music]
hmm
[Laughter]
dude i will finish this place just to
prove that i'm the um trisha i think
you kind of sabotaged yourself if you
had just concentrated on one slice
you had like half of two eaten no that
would have been one full
my strategy was to you know not psych
myself out like i'm almost done with
both of these but
all right because i feel like you did
eat the equivalent of ten
but you don't get credit for well that's
what i'm saying and i was eating it
faster than ethan at the start and then
when i looked at your strategy you're
sitting there munching like a little
[ __ ]
what did you my belly could not handle
it
i mean look i'm about to do it two
two slices well congratulations you're
fat and i'll even finish this to prove
it okay do it
don't do it don't that's disgusting i'll
do whatever it takes for you
i don't want you to eat it i don't want
you to eat it don't
i'm helping you can we try and finish
the story before we do it
i don't want to like food shame you
either if you're hungry
are you i'm sorry i shouldn't do that do
you want to eat it no you did me a favor
no eat it now i feel bad stop stop doing
this eat it here have mine too
here stop stop here this is food shaving
eat it
eat it fatty now i feel bad i knocked it
out of your hand
get that away from me thank you to our
sponsor dominoes
not domino domino's used our audio on
their
tic tac i know it's [ __ ] up dominoes
should we
if they paid me i'd [ __ ] spawn i'd be
eat pizza every day
just give me a reason maybe five
thousand pounds so okay can we ignore
okay hold on
hold on who sent the bomb can we
acknowledge the police that i won
do you acknowledge that oh good thank
you but honestly like i said that's not
competition i want to win
first of all i said that and then you
said no that i want to win every
competition
oh i'm sad well i feel like you did
cheat again on this one because we
weren't able to do 30 minutes
i am a monster i am a pizza monster
although i have to say you
after you showed a strong finish
like you impressed me on that route
because i thought i was like
because you were talking about being
full i was i am my arm ample is why i'm
fat
when i'm full you're not supposed to do
that uh
yeah you don't get to look like us if
you stop when you're full
mo said i like to like the sexiest woman
alive today he said look at all those
curves i said thank you
well that's fine but it doesn't i'm just
that doesn't mean you don't eat when
you're full
i have sex when i'm full sometimes you
know like i'm too full
and so i just had to lay there i'm like
we can have sex i can't do anything i
have to just lay there
god that i think you're eating too often
if like sex and eating
interact intertwined so much lately it's
been that for sure i've had to i had to
get on top
the other day and it was the first time
i was on top in like a month not good
oh i was winded i was winded i felt so
bad i felt like i was suffocating him i
think he'd love
to be suffocated you have a fetish
where's
oh okay he was just fine that's not a
good thing about sex it was just fine
i survived oh my god that's a good
t-shirt
i survived sex with trish i got crushed
by
i love crushing videos though so anyway
okay i will finish this story now
oh god yeah this is the thing that
they're gonna show on all the storage
wars and all those shows
info wars whatever the [ __ ] wars it is
what the [ __ ] is info wars anyways what
does that even mean
there's a war against information oh you
have information no we're gonna put a
war against it
sounds like a right-wing person to meme
it is yeah he's a right-wing conspiracy
theory he's the bush
of 2021 he thinks like hillary clinton
he drinks baby blood and [ __ ] like that
oh yeah but we did say we totally agree
with that i did not say that i think she
drinks baby blood
yeah for sure for sure
so he's right on something okay well a
broken clock is right uh
what is um okay so
so anyway the fbi comes to my house he
says don't open any package we have a
threat so i said oh my god that's
[ __ ] crazy
um that was your reaction oh my god
that's [ __ ] crazy i'd be like
we're going to a hotel [ __ ]
well we have a guard and so i mean no it
wasn't so he just said
wait he says just stand by we have to
reject every package until we
find out if the threat is credible or
not on my lips
you have a little pizza sauce here i
literally think it's cause you spit on
me
no which one here yeah right there well
thanks for telling you weren't gonna
tell me or just let me have that you
just asked me
okay well usually you tell no but you
tell people when they're stuff you want
me to get it for you
yeah but with this don't scrap too much
though because it's right
now dab it okay i got it thank you my
whole face will come off of you scrub
thank you so you stayed
we just said we said everybody look we
can't open any packages if you see
anything
whatever yadda yadda um
and so anyway i just got an email from
the fbi agent this morning saying that
they found out the source of the oh
threat
and that it's not credible threat so it
means that some kid is in really deep
trouble with his parents
probably oh it was a kid i don't know he
did he didn't give any details but
where was it on it probably just like
read it or something right i guess i
have to take it seriously
um it was probably on a deeper like nazi
forum probably not read it isn't there
like the dark web too
there's a dark web yeah it's like the
illuminati
but i i feel like that but yeah it was
crazy i mean we're getting swatted all
the time we've got swatted like 10 times
in the past
do you think maybe don't be as vocal
like i know you're passionate about it
and i'm not saying don't
but i'm saying like i remember i used to
talk about politics i'm like you know
maybe i should not be as vocal about it
because you don't want to like have like
your
little baby hurt or something you know
what i mean and fight
be less opinionated maybe i just think
that the stuff i talk about i think it's
important when i talk about it
it just pisses off so much from the
beginning of this pandemic been talking
been very vocal about it and i think
it's important to
i talk about things that are important
to me and i can't like just
get intimidated especially by some
stupid [ __ ] like
pieces of [ __ ] like they're lit that's
literally their goal they're terrorists
but what about like your audience it's
like okay we're done we're over this
like you know what i mean you're
alienating somebody like susan serena
nice to love her but okay we get it
you're political you know just talk too
much about what i don't talk too much
about politics
you need to be like if i get it if i get
a bump
a bump a bomb threat then the thing is
like
first of all it's important to note that
if you send a bomb threat
the fbi is going to [ __ ] find you
okay and the same thing with swatting
people who swatted me last year uh i'm
still getting doj
letters this guy's on trial he's going
to jail for like 10 [ __ ] years
why are they always so scary-looking
because they're just [ __ ]
they're just the angry yeah they're just
they say you can't tell someone is like
sick in the head by looking at them but
that guy
sometimes you can't i was like you seen
that guy uh the night
the night the dark soccer um yeah that
guy was a [ __ ]
crazy but you know like good looking the
guy that like no but apparently he's
stunk cause he's like never showered
like he's
like an older to fill a room yeah you
need to shower
tip tomorrow tip to all serial killers
shower
because then people think you're not a
serial killer yeah smell good
for sure anyway listen i'm talking about
politics much but there are certain
things that i think are important to
talk about to me personally
okay so i get it not me i'm not
political don't come for me i'm just a
dumb [ __ ] sitting next to you
i don't want to be on these political
shows although fox news if you want me
i'll come in and commentate all day long
you know i was interviewing fox news one
time
i was interviewed for fox news one time
but i don't know if it was an interview
or a date there's a guy named jesse
something on fox news you went on a date
on fox news i don't think so no he's
like
he's a he's like a anchor on fox news
jesse waters yes okay so he like told me
oh i'm gonna interview for a show to be
like a host on fox news this was like
2012.
and i think it was just a date we just
ended up going to nobu
are you serious yeah you were never on
the show
no and it wasn't even an interview he's
like we'll let you know about the show i
don't know he just took you to nobu
yeah but i think he's like mary jessie
waters he was cute was he trying to [ __ ]
you i don't know
did he ever follow him like thinking
about this i was like wait i was
supposed to be on fox news one time and
then i was like
what the [ __ ] would they ask you about
you don't even know where like i used to
be a trump supporter online
not like politically i never voted but
like in online i thought it was like
cool
i'm gonna be crazy and vote for trump
you know but like i didn't even do it i
was just trying to be problematic
honestly don't come from me i literally
could not
i don't like donald trump i only anybody
although the apprentice was a bop love
that show but i do i never watched it
you never watched i wanted to get it so
bad
so do you believe that um is jesse water
still on fox news oh my god that's kind
of i think i think even just supporting
like trans rights is enough to get a
bomb threat these days
i don't get them that's not a challenge
don't try
me i'm with a bomb specialist over there
he's from the middle east he used to
detect bombs in his sleep when he was in
the military he'd be in lebanon he'd be
like
now you're gonna no you don't want to
see now even oh now they're oh my god
should i cut it
now you're in trouble now is good
they're all coming for you now but don't
because he's an actual middle easterner
my fiance is he's ready he's locked and
loaded don't do it
um you don't want to mess with those
hands i don't know if this
i don't know if the story was good but
the point is that you're gonna get
caught if you keep doing this [ __ ] and
me
yeah you're gonna get caught if you keep
doing this [ __ ] what
no to the people doing bomb threats um
the fbi is gonna find you
dude that's scary you have a lot of
weirdness i thought you said it was
because you were jewish though like this
i think it's a common well it's the
people that are doing it
are white nationalists okay they don't
like me because i'm jewish they don't
like me because i speak out on liberal
issues they don't like me because i
talk about vaccines and all this [ __ ]
and i'm like anti-trump i don't like
trump i think trump's like a [ __ ]
dog [ __ ] you don't have so political
though i feel like we don't talk about i
mean i never really hear you talk about
this as well no i don't either but
i guess because people see it when i do
yeah they get super like
the clip of me like you should see what
peop the guys were saying on infowars
about like people are lose having a
meltdown over this tweet i made
did they want to fight you there was one
guy that wanted to fight you that one
guy was like he was so
on some conspiracy theory podcast what
was his name dan you knew it
sapoli it was uh sam tripping
triple triple e he was good he goes
i want to fight this guy or he's like
i'll fight him for charity i was like
[ __ ] i don't even know who you are
oh he was like somebody i don't know but
i was like why am i i'm not going to fly
brian which we honestly should not be
showing his face either
just saying well bret bryant
well brian count his name in the lawsuit
with crystallia he was
yeah that crystallia that girl jane doe
he was like go with my friends and brian
cowan was one of them like to go
somewhere oh she named it that was brian
yeah oh i read it on reddit
weird that's the name i read it on
reddit is that why they call it that
probably that's so funny so anyway
[Laughter]
anyway the guy i'm going to watch all
these i'm going to respond to all that
stuff on wednesday that's a plug for you
okay
don't plug the h3 podcast
if you're interested in this fbi coming
to my house i'm going to respond to all
of these
[ __ ] on wednesday it's gonna be
well on wednesday
on wednesday i'm gonna eat korean fried
cheese on my channel and see if i can
dunk then come on go ahead i don't care
i don't give a [ __ ] come see that what
what would you rather watch her
eat fried cheese or me talk about defend
myself against the attacks
fascist conservative terrorist title
that and see who gets more views title
your wednesday show that i don't kind of
mind eating korean fried cheese and
we'll see you get more views don't put
james charles in the title
put that in the title i'm not gonna put
jimmy okay we'll put that exact in the
title on mine we'll see who gets more
views and aren't
expensive just because you lost pizza
i'm just so full and fat right now
i'm so fat i was thinking i was gonna
break okay
i feel like i'm going to cancel now for
being leftist with you i was canceled
like six years ago
whoever you are i don't know who i am
it's who i'm with at the moment
all right just be just be true to
whatever you believe and then
it doesn't matter what if you have no
beliefs i really don't well you believe
in trans right you believe in gay rights
that's like super i mean
i think that's more just like people
rights they're just like yeah equality
for everybody
that's so conservatives do not believe
in trans rights
well [ __ ] that they are trying they
literally are
and i mean for the most part anti-gay
anti-trans
so you're you're a liberal you're a
liberal issue
they're all secretly like gay and
[ __ ] like in the ass and stuff like
that all those are
for sure they're just like repressed
there was like a really famous story of
like a
of a republican who was like super
anti-gay
and he got outed by from uh from a male
prostitute that he was they were smoking
meth together and [ __ ] all the time
always that's always the case with
everybody
but they're just they don't even care
these people are so psychopaths they
don't even care they're just pandering
to the [ __ ] voters like they
literally don't care
they just know what they have to say to
pander to a conservative audience this
jacket was eight thousand dollars oh six
thousand dollars on leaviton.com
[Music]
it fits me no no designer items fit me
this was the first thing that fit a
big fatty like me honestly i feel like a
cute like my boyfriend plays
football i never had that were you a
football player my boyfriend
plays football and i just crushed two
extra large pizzas
oh i'm the linebacker plot twist i'm
playing the football game tonight
yeah moses is the hot little twink for
sure you're the linebacker
he for sure is you guys should role play
that where he's a cheerleader and you're
the linebacker
i could be into it i guess that'd be
cute bro we just
crushed like can we just take a minute
to before we move on to
appreciate that we just crushed two
extra large pizzas
each and we both don't feel like
throwing up yet
yeah i thought i was gonna puke we
should do that chocolate cake like in
matilda next time remember when brucy
has to eat all the cake
i don't want to do any more eating oh
loser
i think i just had like ten thousand
calories like how many calories how many
calories is it we don't even talk about
the calories i hate that let's not talk
about it it'll really depress me it'll
trigger me oh really
okay okay thank you i was just curious
don't say it it triggers me
for real skis i'll get really depressed
don't tell me
i mean you know it's bad you know it's
bad who's bad
so when i was in a good mood today and
was just like you're in a good mood this
morning
well we started on a really good mood
close your eyes and tell me who i sound
like
hello what's krithi frog here
[Music]
jordan peterson did it sound like kermit
kind of thank you i was doing that in
the car today it kind of ruins the
game when you say the name though oh
yeah
yeah what am i supposed to say you say i
am
i don't know i am can you do impressions
not really i can do impressions i'm
really good i can do one of you okay do
one
daddy that's how you like think i sound
i feel
um daddy
i can't even do one of you you don't
have any like discernible
characteristics that like make you stand
out i've never seen anyone do a good
impression of me all they ever do is
like this they go
and then that's pretty easy though you
know but like in turn i've never seen a
good impression of me
that's funny but it's funny if it's not
meant to be mean like if it's not like
coming from a hateful place then it's
like funny and cute
so anyway i got bomb threats shout out
to the conservatives
um or not i don't want to paint
conservative but really the
the the neo-nazis my family you want to
talk about shout out to his family is
that a meme did i do it
yeah thank you i know you like that
because it won on the h3
you want to talk about dirty dom making
tick tocks about
uh yeah okay so dirty diamonds back
so annoying so just well you know what
annoying is he's like making fun making
light of the situation as if like
you think you can hurt my feelings i get
kicked out of the box he's
so disgusting he looks like a little rat
that needs to be in jail i wish these
people would press charges and i know
it's like
embarrassing it's a lot of work or
whatever but if you ever want to sue
people
there's lawyers that'll do it for pro
bono if you ever want to press charges
it's never too late until it's too late
i think it's like 10 years or maybe
that's gone now but i know it was ten
years i don't know what the statute of
limitations
but look at these people they just get
away with it and guess what he'll
probably do it again because he thinks
he's funny and all these like
kids are like yeah we love you don't let
them get you down do it again
they'll do it again and it's just so
it's like james charles all these new
people come out because
nothing is happening until you go to
jail like austin jones like until like
that happens like then these people keep
doing this [ __ ] yeah
and they think it's funny you should be
on a sex prep registration
for sure he needs to tell people when he
moves into their neighborhood so many
people were like why isn't diamond
canceled and it was kind of because like
dom was already handling exactly no
everyone no everybody like
nobody gives a [ __ ] about dawn but
honestly we should talk about him more
if he's doing this [ __ ] because oh yeah
like now he's like he's i saw a clip of
him being like why did david rubber kick
you out he's like because i was getting
all the [ __ ] or something like that
but yeah oh it was i just thought on
your tic-tacs i thought it was you i
he goes why did why did david dilbert
kick you out of the vlog spot he's like
because i get more [ __ ] than him
i was like first of all we know david
likes to watch so that's not true
and second of all actually you got to
get him drunk to have sex with you
disgusting freak
actually just an r word honestly he's so
gross like and
yeah so anyway he put this out like what
one day ago was it it says yeah one day
ago
the dude like seriously he's for real
he's being accused of r
of uh essay right and he puts out this
tick tock saying you think you could
hurt my feelings it's this tick tock
meme
and the song is bulletproof and he's
saying i got kicked out of the vlog
squad four like what does he want us to
finish this
yeah stupid essay
did you finish it for him did you yeah
and i got i got [ __ ]
i made a tick tock and then they took it
down like in literally five seconds
oh really that's [ __ ] and i left a
comment and then
i think my whole tick tock account's
[ __ ] up for being just for being too
much because yeah i like tried to leave
a comment on one of ela's tick tocks and
and we're like mutuals and it went to
her spam filter
oh you're like blah yeah i'm like oh
this is why you gotta stop
being overtly i'm still kind of new to
tick tock so i don't know
keep it on youtube where they let you
speak your mind you know yeah
it makes me appreciate tick tock is it's
weird it's like on one hand they're like
don't call out this guy for being a
legitimate
essayist but oh here's
and here's an animal being [ __ ]
tortured with like
10 million views i'm like i'm sorry what
this is so [ __ ] up and so disgusting
he's disgusting ever since the war at
least david's like loki hiding and stuff
and like
they need to but it's like when they
come back it's like really look what
happened when chrisley came back he got
hit with another lawsuit because these
people are like oh he's back like
because they will just keep doing it
like if people are back on everyone's
side like as soon as people are like
dirty dog he'll just keep doing this
[ __ ] again because they're sick in the
head it's not just a normal person that
does something once it's like
a pattern like all these people yeah
there's always going to be someone to
defend them
and to buy their story and to until
that's not until there's not like one
day
it will be there will be there's always
someone like he's not michael jackson
where he has talent you know what i mean
eventually some people are gonna be like
okay this like same thing with david
it's not like they're like talented
people that people like well we like his
music it's like they're idiots that's
what they do for like that's what
they're known for
so they do for a living like this is the
comment i keep seeing it's like so this
guy supposedly jokes about it but david
loses everything okay makes sense it's
like no this guy had nothing to lose
that's why he spoke
exactly exactly it's not people always
go why is david getting cancelled and
nothing happening dom it's like they're
dom is [ __ ] yeah he's nothing to take
from him but david kept like progressing
forget then he had all this [ __ ] and you
know like eventually yeah like hopefully
he'll come back and
it has been enough time and he'll like
learn whatever but like dom and all
these people are just like and if you
make light of it and joke then you're
like a piece of [ __ ] but you know what
this
is pretty ballsy i was like this guy is
[ __ ] out of his mind to be posting
this
but you know but you but there are there
are youtubers that's like oj that's like
oj posting a tick tock after the
murders be like oh
he did remember that interview
that was after he was acquitted and he
can't shoot oj he's such a psycho
hey twitter world yeah that's what he
says he's on twitter now oh
and he always goes hello twitterworld
it's yours truly
i do not want him on the guest as a
podcast guest
did you see the psychic reading on us
saying
and you know amphideity someone did a
psychic reading yeah they did a tarot
card reading on us you know that kid
that does the tarot cards he's like in a
pink background i'm sure you've seen him
before
i watch it it's not anything crazy other
than what did he
we're gonna try and come and separate us
someone who has
a lot of who is
someone close to david who's really mad
at us for taking away all their money
he's gonna try to separate them they're
gonna separate
you saw all that in the tarot card yeah
and first they come from me as a
distraction but they're really going for
you
wow everyone's been tweeting me about it
it's like a really like thing that
people believe in because i guess some
of his predictions have come true
so everyone's like be careful there's no
syndromes on youtube the tarot card
thing is just so stupid
no it he hasn't had one come true i know
him i met him on twitter if you make
enough predictions one of them comes
true
yeah he did predict that trisha would
get triggered in the future
wow you're [ __ ] psychic yeah you and
everybody watches
i was watching it late at night and i
got really scared and then moses was
like that's like an obvious thing
people are all quacks they're all quacks
what's the name of the channel and for
deity ant oh like ant
and phradity like and then aphrodite
i think it's like yeah like that oh the
first thing comes up is scammer
oh sassy psychic tarot reader that's on
instagram oh he has like a friend of his
wig look at that pink and black wig
yo this guy is such a [ __ ] scammer
that's like [ __ ]
he bought a vip package well i don't
give a [ __ ] like but like you can't just
put that [ __ ] out there it's not it's
not okay
he says it's for entertainment yeah but
it's [ __ ] you can't put that [ __ ]
out there because
oh wait three months ago no no go to his
videos that's the home page all my
psychic predictions that came true yeah
and where's the one where they all
didn't come true are you in there is
that even the yellow hat i can't see
that part
look how young you look okay skinny
legend yeah this is a really old photo
wow
that was pre-luxe pro days oh yeah
we like like super though love looks
better to be stable in mind than
skinny box oh yeah okay go to the video
didn't you say last time i'd rather be
known as skinny than half but then what
was it
some kind of good line rather be known
as skinny than
happy or good whatever i don't think i
said that
anyway i feel like this [ __ ] is lame
it's irresponsible
he says it's for entertainment well well
trisha paid his friend of me he's right
there
john was psychic listen for me to take
him seriously for his trailer
it says all my predictions came true i
want to see all your predictions that
didn't come true make that as your
trailer
you [ __ ] well that wouldn't be as
selling we like it exactly
no we don't i like i think he's scamming
him inside likes you you shouldn't be
saying [ __ ] like that and people taking
it seriously like
they say it's for entertainment purposes
well you said you believe it
i do so exactly bro he's selling me
vitamins what is this [ __ ] he has bones
no shame oh my god we live for
you should we do the maid trend
everyone's being french maids on tick
tock now
wait this is is this how he dresses
every video no but it's like a thing
these are cafes
i don't have an audio japanese reading
which i'll put a link to up here
and a lot of my friends went around the
eight minutes that she would do the
war between david and frenemies would be
over but it is definitely not over
wait he's are these even like physical
tarot cards or is he online yeah he's
has a camera looking over him he's like
dealing the cards and like it's
look looking over his hand bro these
likes weird anime tarot cards
like these aren't even like the these
aren't even like uh it looks like daphne
from scooby-doo
like at least give me like the weird
mystical astrology [ __ ] you know
these are like [ __ ] anime cards like
i'm sorry dude no
no we don't like it i like it i
downvoted
i don't like it i think it's good
there's some cool lord of the rings
tarot cards for you yeah
the merlin well you better be careful he
said people are actually gonna try and
attack you they're gonna use me as a
distraction people someone just sent me
a pipe bomb
oh he it's already come true like i'm
just saying people have been trying to
attack me
basically for the last three years like
everything
yeah oh maybe it was the light of
darkness the old gnome with the fairy on
his head
not dope though we should do tarot cards
someone made terror cards out of me
we should get front of me tarot cards i
don't like i don't like
devils you literally were like oh what's
wrong with the devil in a little nos
video like a couple weeks ago
no i don't have a problem with the devil
i just don't like people that act like
they can tell the future and [ __ ] i just
think it's a scam and it's not cool
psychics tarot card people astrology
readers i think they're all [ __ ]
like straight up scammers and i really
it's one of the things that really
triggers me it triggers you
kind of because like because it's so
[ __ ] up like you look at these
these psychics and they're they're
getting people so worked up
talking to their dead family members and
[ __ ] and it's just it's [ __ ] up i
think people just want something to
believe in
yeah but like who is he to make to to be
that to pretend to be that person and
profit from their misery and suffering
it doesn't matter that they want to
believe it it's not real
and he's profiting real to some people
because all manifestations of
if someone wants to believe that's what
happens and then sometimes they give
they say [ __ ] like what that guy's
saying where he's like
like all of a sudden this abs this guy
is just making [ __ ] up is actually
informing your life decisions like
there's something that's going to happen
between warming i'm going to be
triggered whether he's out
he said you're getting nervous he said
someone's going to try to attack me
through you or something i was getting
nervous i was just saying did you see
i mean it's gonna happen oh but someone
said we're a duo that's so powerful that
someone needs to try and separate us
that's how powerful we are right now
he said that no someone in the comments
said wow
that means frenemies is so powerful
that's gonna take a foreign
wait till you see us eat four
extra-large pizzas in one city that's
how we get our power
we just increased our gravitational pull
i'll tell you that yeah try and get us
out of these seats
we're like sucked together let's go
fight that guy
i i really hate these [ __ ] psychics
bro i don't like fighting
yeah i could should we get in the boxing
ring i want to i've been saying that
before beginning
i've been saying that since i'd boxed
you you're the only person in the world
i'd actually bought we should like
wrestle like andy kaufman style
no yeah i'm not rich he wrestled woman
all the time i'm not gonna wrestle you
in a box you just wanna punch me in the
face well i'm not gonna arrest you
there's so much contact
like i'm not gonna hug you and roll
around on the floor that's not
wrestling well it is kind of oh my gosh
i have to grab you and go to the ground
i'm just not i don't want to do that
with you
so you just want to punch me in the face
yeah i said i'll box you
i'll wrestle cause i'm a good wrestler
and women can wrestle men
you've got crazy center of gravity i
wrestled guys if we're in the same
weight class we can wrestle them all day
long so we are the same weight
i'm not wrestling you you're a baby
i'll box you you're a [ __ ] that'd be
fun i don't want to get punched in the
face i can wrestle i just don't get
punched i'll get i'll do you i'll deal
you body shots only
right in the spleen that sounds more
sexual
you only want to hit my butt you're the
only person on youtube because you know
how everyone's always trying to do these
boxing matches like this is the new
choice
you're the only percent box pay-per-view
pay-per-view event russell wwe
wrestlemania
ethan versus trish no you're scared i'm
a governor that's disgusting i don't
want to get on the floor and tell you
you think guys are doing that for sexual
gratification
yeah she said she's saying like wwe yeah
that's fake
you want to do a choreographed bit with
me i mean i can do college wrestling too
it's not but you're talking about like
grappling ethan
like real wrestling but she's talking
about like wwe
well that's i don't have much money but
guys i think it'd be super entertaining
guys that wrestled guys don't do it for
sexual gratification i know
but like i'm not doing that with you
that's a you problem if you have a
such a problem you can't touch another
woman's body without it being sexual or
weird that's awesome it's not it's just
it is
it's just no it's literally you have a
weird thing i'm not touching people
you're like very like have a sexual
issue
going on no i don't want to wrestle you
um were you disgusting did something
happen to you as a child
no i feel like something did why because
i don't want to wrestle you no
but you have a touching thing in general
where you can't help am i crazy for
being
uncomfortable wrestling trisha and did
you find that odd
thank you but why i'm just trying to
understand why because you're thinking
of it as a sexual way you're saying i
just
don't wanna i just don't wanna touch and
roll around okay because why you think
of it sexual you think it's gross it's
just gross it's like doing it with like
let's say
i i just think it's gross i don't what
do you want what would continue like
let's say what doing it with who
you just think my body is gross like you
don't want to touch it i don't really
want to wrestle anyone to be totally
honest
you were you just said it's just you and
now you're changing your time i was
going to say like a sister
or something mm-hmm okay then i thought
about it and i just i was just thinking
about that
right i was just going back to the thing
about me secretly wanting to have sex
with you no i don't think so at all i
think there's like a deeper root issue
where you like either i'm trying to
figure it out if like you think my
body's gross or it's
it's like you're thinking about a sexual
way so you think if it's one of two
things you either think i'm disgusting
you don't want to touch my body or
you're thinking of a sexual way and i'm
not i'm just i'm trying to try to figure
out what it is
so you think that you just said girl so
it's more like you just think it's
disgusting and don't touch my body which
is fine i'm not like saying you have to
i'm just trying to figure out the rules
you you think if it was a different girl
that i was more attracted to i would
want to i was trying to figure out what
it was is it
because you think it's like i want to
think on your body or you thought it was
gross
but you told me it was just you rewind
the tape to five minutes ago and you're
like it's just you
i i revised my statement and i thought
about and i said i don't want to wrestle
anybody okay
i'll box you okay i'll fight and i
already said no that i'm not doing that
so
that's when why do you why are you
insisting on wrestling i don't want to
wrestle anymore i'm not insisting it i'm
saying that's like something that i did
in
high school like it's a completely
normal thing it's not a sexual thing if
you're a repulsor or something by my
body that's the one thing
but wrestling okay that's what i'm
asking i never said i was repulsed by
your body but i'm asking is it a sexual
thing you don't want to do it because
you think it's weird why do you keep why
are you so
i'm just trying to figure out the answer
like truly because it sounds a little
misogynistic which is fine
but if it's because you don't like my
body or you think it's a sexual thing
that's a different story that's why i'm
just trying to figure out where you're
coming from i'm not mad i'm literally
just trying to figure it out because
that's interesting it's there is
something deep rooted there because i've
wrestled guys in high school
and stuff like that and it was never
sexual it wasn't that they were pulsed
by me because i was in the weight class
you were you were actually
on the wrestling team yeah i wrestled in
high school yeah oh
of course you want to wrestle me you've
got all this like yeah you got
experience
and it wasn't meant to be that way i'd
not i didn't say anything about
sexuality i'm trying to figure out why
that's what i was trying to get down to
and you're not really giving me clarity
but it doesn't matter i mean it doesn't
matter
you don't do it don't do it's not like
i'm mad about it why do we have to
psychoanalyze me
it's not it's like truly like i felt
like wow that's i took a little bit of
offense to it because i did wrestle in
high school and it is such a thing for
me where it's like oh i don't want to
wrestle a girl why
oh because she has boobs or oh cause
she's fat or whatever it is and so i'm
just trying to figure out why
it's misogynistic where it came down to
it in high school if guys don't want to
wrestle me it's because they're
misogynistic that they don't want to
wrestle a girl
that i agree with if you're doing a
competitive sport and they don't want to
wrestle you yeah but you were talking
about competing and you're like
wrestling you're like oh i don't touch
your body so i was like okay now is that
because you're repulsed by my body
or because you think it's a sexual thing
and you don't want to cross that line so
that's what i was trying to figure out
i just don't want to touch anybody in
that way okay i'm just trying to figure
out the answer i think it's really
important i think it's really like
i just think is it that important it is
okay it's important to you
i don't like misogynistic people at all
like i really don't i'm not saying you
are that's why i was trying to figure
out the root of it but i understand why
you're so upset because you're dead
yes you are i'm really not i was like
actually trying to figure out like oh is
this like a misogynistic thing or is it
like you're being funny or as a sexual
thing i'm just trying to figure it's not
because you're a girl
i would it's not that i'm i do we're
competing all the time
okay it's just the wrestling if i was
misogynistic i wouldn't we're always
competing
right and you're always beating me and
i'm saying oh you beat me again
okay got it so that's not misogynistic
right
i'm not sure i have to like think about
it
it's interesting so would it make so
should it make you feel better if we
wrestled
oh definitely not now after all that
after you said it was uncomfortable
i'm not about not doing consent oh my
god all right come on
no
ah jesus christ that took a tangent
i just don't want to touch anybody okay
you changed your story a few times but
okay
i thought about it okay let's move on we
love a
thought out king let's wrestle [ __ ] it
let's just [ __ ] wrestle i want to
wrestle jones what's his name
i think he would beat me oh yeah i'll
wrestle him he's husky you go for a
chipotle i'll go for
alex jones i wonder if we'd have a good
uh
wrestling match yeah i don't know
anything about wrestling though are you
talking about now me and you oh as i'm
about now i'm talking about another guy
you moved on to alex jones all right if
he consents of course
so james i'm just glassed by my body or
sexualized by my body i didn't say
either of those things okay
all right james charles yeah let's go
james charles feel like i gotta get away
get away get away but you know that i
don't and i won't stop because you know
i gotta win every day day so you don't
really wanna pop me just know that
you'll never stop me and i know i can be
a little cocky
we can get a copyright claim what was
that is that that good that you think
it's gonna happen
every time i get it then i gotta go i
gotta get in i gotta float wait what is
that i think it
is that eminem or something that's the
right oh busta
busta rhymes is that the one where he's
got the big boxing gloves
i never saw a music video by busta
rhymes actually i just knew the song
james charles dude the fact that we can
even conduct this
episode with two extra-large pizzas in
our stomach is kind of epic like
it's not as bad as i thought it would be
like let's get some props in the chat
for two big
[ __ ] mon pizza eating monsters found
it don't clap for that moses he's not a
monster
he loves your curves and we're drinking
lemon water so we're skinny
skinny legends okay james charles
11th under asia when's the front of
these cups coming i want those
are we getting those are you candid i
really wanted those no we are working on
cops actually
yeah james charles had a
seven eleventh underage if you want to
talk about someone who should be in jail
someone should be on a sex offender list
11th underage boy comes forward boys 16
and appears to have exchanged photos
with james
this one was kind of the worst one yet
because you can clearly see here let me
show it
again i'll just i gotta mute it because
it has cop okay
he says it's so small i can't see it
full screen um i i'm just gonna play it
i have all the dm's
on a screen shot because that's tick
tock for you
so if i have the timeline right
the guy he told
him he was 16 and james said here let me
show you the screenshots
because before james was always like oh
they lied about their a's they lied
about their age
but at this one we can clearly see first
of all
how many photos they've exchanged
um james he said he asked james to erase
the photos
that he sent he hey wait who asked james
the kid
oh i can't really he says james have he
says james
you have nothing like no pics of me from
when we snapped right he said uh no
okay sorry for asking legit my picks
it's fair to ask nothing trouble before
it just came out of nowhere didn't know
why you asked randomly he's sketched out
because he's like wait but why did he
ask this do we know
what happened like did it leak or
something i don't know i mean he like he
said he is right there oh you know just
he's embarrassed he doesn't want
pictures you know what i mean yeah i get
that he sent james charles nude pics of
a 16 year old naked body i mean
he brought he says yeah it just came to
my mind i want to be sure he says yeah
okay
and then the next one so this is when
their conversation started i believe
december 30th here let me check back
because this is kind of important
that i should just be banned i mean it's
snapchat oh my god it's
so awful yeah i was talking about that
before it's like so disturbing running
people's lives and they're so young
so this this appears to come after but
he says
um oh wait no yeah
this shows wait where's the one where it
says
is it okay wow there's a lot
um
here's him being a douche you just
giving me a bunch of dumb
excuses what okay so here
this is the crazy [ __ ] right here okay
he says
okay does it show the date on this
he says how old are you james asks him
he says 16 don't be mad at me laugh my
ass off
upside down smile i hate age but i'll be
17
soon though and james says still illegal
left my ass off
he goes really left my ass off now this
was apparently
the kid explains before they exchanged
photos
oh although to me it doesn't really
matter before or after yeah yeah of
course but i mean this is clear
so wait because he always is claiming i
didn't know their age but in this one
the kid says i am 16
and you can see james going lol and does
he ask for the pictures after does it
show that date i mean i believe this
person i'm just saying
according to what love said i'm not
seeing the dates on this but according
to what the kid
said is that it's out of order and that
he told him his age before they
exchanged photos
am i tagged in this why does it say it
just like fish was he tagging me
wasn't lying about what she said wait
why yeah yeah apparently
i didn't say anything he was a creep
because i called this out last year he's
hanging out with 16 year olds there's
something wrong with everyone's like
it's fine you can be best friends with
the 15 year old no it's [ __ ] weird
apparently he posted a while ago and
nobody believed him and everyone [ __ ] on
him too
which is like common with james charles
so like here you have a clear picture of
james should not have a platform he
should not be allowed on i don't
understand
not to be allowed how is he how is he
not banned i don't understand this like
on tick tock and stuff like that like if
these kids admitted
sexting minors how are they still on
there i don't know i kind of agree that
these platforms need
especially snapchat i mean snapchat
needs to ban him from snapchat first of
all immediately
and like i keep saying the fbi i hope to
god is getting a warrant
to seize his phone and computer because
he's definitely
in possession of child pornography oh
my god yes i mean just proof right there
in that message
i mean that kid got 10 years in prison
for having like twerking videos of girl
that he has like
naked like pictures of guys and stuff
like that but anyway
snapchat should definitely be banning
james he is
he is explicitly using their platform
to prey on children first well snapchat
a hole should just be gone
it'll take someone pressing charges like
someone like their parents need to press
charges or something like
it has to be that and why aren't they
like oh i know it's like
so much but it's like you really well
there's been enough now that i'm
i'm thinking it's likely to happen
there's 11 underage boys now i mean one
of these parents
one of the teachers that molested me he
got in trouble years he went to prison
years later for child porn and i should
have said something sooner but like
he had all these pictures of like gross
underage students and he was like my
middle school teacher and byron illinois
and like got arrested for
i said the word but whatever yeah but
it's insane like if you don't say
something like it just keeps happening
it just keeps happening but it's not the
victim's fault either
it's not but like because that's what's
up because you know what's the worst
part about being a victim of that
that i have like the most sympathy for
is that you become a victim of this
heinous
crime and then all of a sudden you feel
guilty because
now you feel responsible for everyone
else who comes after you
because you didn't do more to help i
mean this it's [ __ ] up that that
becomes something
that you now have to that you you not
only did this
heinous thing happen to you but now you
carry this burden of feeling like you
have to do something about it you know
um yeah it just goes both way i think
when i happened to me you're just like
it's just it was just like a lot of a
lot to like have to go do all that i was
like oh i don't want to do it's just
like a lot to have to talk about it but
at the same time it helps so many people
and at 16 like you know you could do
really great things i know i get it you
don't have to do anything you're not
comfortable with but
it's a heroic thing it's hard that's
what i'm saying
but it's like now you have this whole
thing that's like
this whole other burden of having to
deal with this person you know like
that's why i don't have really a problem
with people coming out with these
receipts and stuff because at least it's
something it's like their way of getting
some sort of like
yeah of course you know note and like i
don't know
nothing will happen until like they're
like something legal gets involved and
sometimes it takes years like that
austin jones case was two years and
sometimes it took a while but
well i'm curious to see what happens
with james because i don't think he
should be allowed to ever come back or
have a platform we're just even like
morphy just still like more they're
still
sitting on the fence like here let's go
to let's go to morphe right now
he's like admitted he's admitted to this
like it's not
alleged yeah they said oh we're looking
into it it's like bro
here let me let me send you a [ __ ]
item i i can send you an
xl at this point morphy is trash so
let's see so trash
let's go to um laura lee and jeffree
star's palette for having like
racism in the past which you know
rightfully so but you're not gonna take
away an actual like
let's see james charles right here still
on the website
james charles right [ __ ] here on the
website you know what it is they
probably have just like
bought a bunch of his [ __ ] so they're
like oh what do we do with these
dirty dirty dirty money then that's like
blood money you know honestly it's gonna
be like bad karma that whole
morphe thing that's going to come down
that's my prediction amphideity
it's different sidekicks aren't real
here's a psychic prediction morphe is
going to go in the garbage yeah real
soon
here's what the tarot cards say this
website won't even be up in six months
here's the little diddler here this
card's called the little diddler
that's the tarot card okay how about
like something else
well i'm just trying to make up my own
okay well that really makes sense
the little the little uh what was it
called the guy who would play the flute
and all the kids would come along the
pied piper
yeah he's the pied piper the [ __ ] is a
pie pie i swear to god there's a fable
where he plays the flute and all the
kids follow him
right then is that james charles yeah
that's what i'm saying that's his new
name
follow him off a cliff right he like
kills him so james charles is the pied
piper
oh that's from an emma song best believe
somebody's bae in the pied piper
no is that james charles someone is
paying the pied piper
morphy
i think he gets the award at the
steamies next year of just like
an actual violence oh i can't wait for
the steamies and james charles cuz all
the awards should we do the venue
i thought we were i'm so that's done you
have to play so wait wait wait
what are we doing so does it happen at
the end of the year
we did in january at the beginning of
okay so we usually have awards
work is like at the beginning of the so
we should
um i have to get in touch with a like uh
a booking company and just have them do
everything i know one i don't mean i
don't know if they're still around
because of the pandemic but i knew when
they did my tours
oh so they used to be full screen and
then they started their own full screen
no there's not them anymore they like
started their own people that worked
there
oh okay good full screen used to do my
tours but no that's a different company
so let's book a venue i'm down
dude this team is i wonder if anyone
will come collect their award
nobody is coming here we'll invite them
we'll we'll send them official
invites some people show up for the
razzies yeah what's the razzies
it's like the oscars but for bad movies
oh but that's like
that's a little more kind of more fun
james charles uh
most prolific predator congratulations
come collect your award the fbi is
behind the stage waiting for you
ooh maybe i could have chris hanson
present that one well christian's not on
the up and up right now
but like he is on youtube now i bet i
could get chris hanson to present that
yeah i think he's a little just imagine
he goes he goes
i'm chris hanson i'm chris hanson and
today
we're presenting the most prolific
predator
james charles have a seat right over
here please and there's a seat
yeah he just turned himself in dude that
would be the best
um
yeah we love it anyway he's a creep he's
disgusting he's a monster um
and i despise him and i think he's a
he's disgusting i really i mean what can
i say i mean he's a monster is he back
to posting like is he on tick tock and
stuff posting or
no he's he's in my at least he has the
decency to disappear
yeah you need to for a little while
that's just like what you do
like david has the decency to disappear
yeah
dom is out there being like oh well hey
they calling me a essayist oh my god
that's so insane to me i mean shane's
been gone for about a year now
like people just disappear where's the
angela wallace did he disappear did he
do something what if he was no
handle no he's still around he's not
making videos i never seen anything
about him
he's always no he's making videos he has
like a second channel he always supposed
to
uh i want to watch a second channels
don't start a second channel
don't you have like 10 channels and no
one knows about any of them no one
watches the second channel because
they're confused they're like what
so james charles is a creep dirty dom is
a creep jake paul is a creep
did you see this new allegation most of
these are males i'm not trying to be a
reverse misogynistic but
this is crazy how they're all men well
yeah i mean
okay you gotta talk about jackpot the
jakewell thing was crazy yeah
i watched your podcast live so then we
went to go watch the video of the girl
because actually
i didn't know about it i didn't know or
whatever and it's
pretty really repulsive yeah it's
rapalje
well she's oh hey
i feel like i get something cool like
that i think i said that before i don't
ever heard it i just hear about impulses
i thought
okay it's not another plug for impulses
they're not stopping me i told you i'm
kidding they're still gonna record while
he's in puerto rico
they're like hey so um boy that was
crazy what happened on like they put a
podcast up today we're like wow i can't
believe that january 6th riot was crazy
i mean they're talking to jeff whittick
before so they even put up the gym next
week he said
mike just tweeted this is so pointless
like next week who's gonna watch that
[Music]
[Laughter]
tune in next week with our interview
with uh hillary clinton announces her
run for president
by the way i watched hp podcast and you
said you hate the massing your math
singer i love you if you want to have me
on it i'll be the
little flamingo or whatever i'll be a
character yeah you you're more ambitious
than me in terms of like getting out
there and stuff
i just like i support you i support you
being on the math singer i'll be the
math singer
can i tell you if i am or no what do you
why wouldn't you tell me oh i don't know
if i'm allowed to say if i'm a messenger
like i can talk about it on the podcast
or no
not not until you get unmasked because
why it's a bias
can i say i'm the fling flamingo the
whole the whole point is that
it's anonymous people don't know who you
are i don't think they would want to but
the
the judges the judges wouldn't need to
know no they don't
that's not that's part of the show is
the judges try and guess who the person
i'm sure they did not know who logan
paul oh they have no that was what i
loved
yeah oh yeah i'm sure a stone of it is a
stage they're all like oh
i was like they have no idea they have
me on i get a hundred thousand views on
my youtube videos and they're like oh my
god it's twitch
it's internet they literally said it's
internet sensation logan paul
i remember him from the suicide forest
yikes well dance i think
if anyone knows no it was a good joke i
wish i could i don't know
well he said if they know him from
anywhere it's the suicide forest thing i
was like you're probably right
that's just kind of true i mean most
people in the mainstream what do they
know
it worked out for him though look at him
now he's on matt singer he was just on
wwe he's killing him
he's literally killing it once he found
that body his career has been
killing it what do you think i'm known
for
anything probably you're i mean crying
on the kitchen floor
really still i feel like i'm gonna land
so long well i'm just saying if you're
not for anything
oh i love it that's the only thing like
people know me for like my reaction
videos and i haven't made one like five
years
really so if you're messing are they
like we love his reaction they'd
probably say podcaster at this point
right not vape nation uh the
the internet sensation podcast host
ethan
klein like you don't you have no idea
who i am
you should get a steamy next year for
the most swatted
thank you i'd love to take that
nomination i don't
i don't know of anyone else who's had an
fbi agent show up at their house yeah i
don't either
oh speaking but back to james charles
pewdiepie finally says james charles did
you see that
i with the mentos ken i didn't watch the
kind of went off on him so i guess
that's good remember we're saying like
he doesn't have anything
yeah i mean what's what's there
what's left to to debate all right let's
hear it
so jake paul we watch this girl's video
which by the way she looked
16 in the video and then a couple years
ago i was like how old is she she looks
so young in the video she's so young and
then she showed the pictures of when she
knew jake she had like blue hair
again like like 15 years old i was like
well she has a big tick tock account old
is she her name is justine
pear justine paradise
she's like an influencer i guess yeah
who she is this broke my heart because
it's like
i think she takes talks about it pretty
lightly but it's like this is like such
long-term effects like being the way she
described being like
forced into something like you know it's
like they don't think it's trauma at the
time because what should i last 30
seconds
or something but that's so traumatic
when it's like so quick like that and
like
it's it's a lot and i could tell she
hasn't like fully even processed and
understood it like it's just like
a lot i never heard someone online
describe it so
graphically too usually they just say i
was assaulted or something
but she explicitly described graphically
and also very like
casually which is why it like bothered
me because i was like thinking like this
is gonna like
[ __ ] up long term i see tana now do a
bunch of tech talks like you know i
think this is a [ __ ] meme
she talks a lot about like and it's she
says it's about a lot of people because
people were like is this about jason is
this about shane you know because like
shane peed on her when she freshly
turned 18 or
she like had her on him yeah i just saw
it it's like
someone retweet like uh from two
thousand and
he made like a sex tape with her yeah
and well other people too like a lot of
and she said it was la la and then of
course like jason like trying to kiss
her and
she's like it wasn't a date until he
made it a date like and now she's seeing
it she
just [ __ ] me up and it's like so
interesting she's saying it because
she's known as being like a wild party
channel whatever
and so the fact that she's saying like
this is like [ __ ] me up mentally and
stuff and she's singing that at 25. i
think of her at 30.
like 30 not to keep bringing this up but
i wasn't freaking mental hospital at 33
times over because i thought i was fine
too i was like oh i love being like this
person
like i'm an escort i suck dick for money
whoo like i loved it and then like later
on down the line you're just like [ __ ]
that was some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
right and you really do like any i
talked about it so casually too when i
was younger i was always like yeah like
this happens
i did this whatever you know it's like
but it's so [ __ ] up long term and the
way she was talking so casually because
she also mentioned a lot like
her phone and how she was embarrassed by
her phone model and i was like oh she's
talking about this so casually she's
going to marry it to like
a phone model you know what i mean and i
was like but that's just like a [ __ ]
thing it's not her it's like that's like
some it really is like the way we're
like taught to like think about these
things as like girls like it just
happens like that just happens like
it's [ __ ] up it's sad yeah i felt bad
i i know what you i mean
that's it and she texted him to hang out
again and i know that too because so
many people be like why would you
hang out again it's like you're so like
dude there's people online trying to
discredit her and it's the same [ __ ] you
[ __ ] always hear from these people
about like i don't believe her
because like why didn't she stop him so
great i was like you're a [ __ ] idiot
or why was she talking about her phone
it's like you're a [ __ ]
douchebag why did you reach back out to
him it's like dude you
can you just [ __ ] have like an ass
a milligram of but all those are traits
of people being like
abused you know because like reaching
out to someone that abused you is like
so
super common like it's super it's like
textbook yeah of course that's like red
flags all around like that's
not like something that's like shows
that she was like abused in some way by
this person
and in multiple ways so there's like a
whole time
this one was really just i i don't i
didn't really see anything coming of
this
jake paul one but i'll um because people
are just so
numb by it i think so too it's like oh
my god another one
when i hear about james charles i don't
even know about that one i'm like even
me i'm like okay it's another one
because nothing's being done about it
because this is the real person i know
right but people are literally just
being it's another one until someone
pressed charges
like the crystalia girl the year old
with the lawsuit like that's like the
first thing that happened that she's not
being paid off and now all these easy
littles are made public and people are
like oh this is kind of nasty and gross
and like there's no chance ever and i'll
keep talking about because we weren't
talking about anymore like he's canceled
what i was like he's not canceled he's
back and people are giving him thumbs up
and subscribe to his patreon so
he's not canceled he still has a
sickness he's not getting help he
doesn't talk about getting help he just
tries to deflect by his baby and
not his wife all of a sudden he has a
wife but
i will s yeah the thing about crystalia
is that like
i don't it bothers me a little bit how
when he came back
all of his content is about his family
and his baby now so it's so gross it's
like deflecting
like i know i have a son and like i
don't
put him in a lot of photos and stuff
because
it's just such an easy way to like
minute i just feel like he's
manipulating
somebody he's like even though the whole
world hates me i just look at my son's
eyes and i'm like that's all that
matters and it's like
he never talked about this stuff before
it's so many i watch it honestly because
he disgusts me
i didn't even know he was i didn't even
know he had was like first of all even
engaged or that he was due to have a
baby i watched the podcast all the time
religiously
yeah he was like this girl my girl and
now she has a name kristen and oh we
were supposed to get married for endemic
i was like what the [ __ ]
it's so [ __ ] and he's trying to like
save face and i hate that no more people
are talking about it because if you read
the
if you read the lawsuit of the 17 girl
and the things you said to her really
and like the manipulation and like
saying that she has to do this and oh
now she's the number two girl because
she won't do this and he goes you just
don't please me enough you don't say you
said no to me
all this crazy [ __ ] it just is so
disgusting and i was just like everyone
hates me and comes sweating my patreon
and everyone's like thumbs up chris we
missed you it's like the thing is when
you show the baby it's like
you're it's so compelling you people to
like because you're not
of course yeah yeah it's great
that's what you talked about on this
podcast and it's it's disgusting and
anyways
i just feel like more people talk about
this [ __ ] because especially because all
these girls are like 16 17 and it's like
stop with these people that are like
they're so and a lot of people oh they
know what they're doing and stuff like
that it's like they're
16 and 17. like what do you expect like
yeah yeah of course they know they're
famous or whatever and like whatever but
it's like not their fault it's like not
their fault that you guys like screwed
them over and they're like this is my
thing
yeah it's six yeah you're just like at
16 you're just like
hypnotized by a famous person words will
do anything
but anyway here's here's the timeline of
this accusation because like
i think all these accusers are real
people and this girl is really credible
and they all it's it's exhausting but
like they all deserve to be heard
it sucks that you get that you get
fatigued from just
this i'm calling it youtube you like
that
the band like me too youtube like
youtube
sounds like a copyright issue with no
bono different
you too it's you i'm not copyrighting it
no it's just a gag
uh sounds like two things youtube
that's the play on words you too
because it's like youtube me too oh oh
how about
just we too
but it's a play on youtube i don't like
it we'll think of something else
everyone else liked it who is everyone
else h3 crew everybody
hold it right now pull it on the screen
who am i going to pull there's two
people here
no on the computer on youtube nobody's
watching
it's not live oh my god nobody's
watching and everyone just hates our
show now he's watching right now
if you like uh me too
type i'm scared if you want like me to
type ethan foot soldiers unite i hate
the flesh
and if you have the hate ow
wait listen i listened to this podcast
call i never listened i listened for the
first time yesterday because they had a
good guest on it was holly madison
and this girl it's called like it's a
it's the daddy one
and yeah you everybody it she says daddy
a lot every five seconds she's like
daddy gang this is what's going on and
she kept saying it like the foot
shoulder thing
yeah and i was like this is so it's like
she was interviewing holly madison right
a former
i'll tell you why that foot soldiers is
better no because it's like foot
soldiers
shake hey daddy gang this is what's
happening and then guess what daddy gang
after this and i was like a stop
we're not fine we're not five-year-olds
we don't need a fan first of all i don't
constantly consider i'd be like okay
foot soldiers listen up i don't say it
i think you do that's how it sounds to
me and second of all mine's ironic
okay we're talking about wiki feet we're
talking about tanking people's wiki feed
scores okay so it's not that serious
i have put fairies and they're going to
take yours
please actually someone said i need to
hype you up more all the comments last
week we're like you know
okay nevermind okay all the you know
let's pull some tarot cards there'll be
feet and [ __ ]
pizza and uh i hype up your feet my foot
fair is go
go give ethan more ratings on that oh
you're calling your gang the foot
fairies
on wiki feet go hype ethan up on
wikifeet man wait you gotta find your
own [ __ ] you can't be a foot fairy
yeah i can you're not the foot what do
you want to compete you want to go
toe-to-toe
literally no we're hyping each other up
my foot fairies are going to help
soldiers and foot fairies yeah okay and
anybody can be a fairy
it's not like girls or gays or anything
is anybody you can be a fairy
if you're a straight male yeah okay
can i get back to the series every time
you have a teddy bear in your shirt you
look like a teddy bear i keep going back
and forth i'm like oh little teddy bear
i want to give you some porridge
you look like a little thing the second
time goldilocks been brought up this
episode
yeah ever since then i've been thinking
about how you look like a little bear
okay
you do have little bear eyes that's why
your son's so cute because he looks like
a little teddy bear too
his name's actually teddy okay it is so
cool
yeah um okay so first of all this girl
that scared me i thought someone was
coming in because we were just talking
about like those the threats and almost
i see someone walking and i'm like oh
you were not fazed that's moses i saw
his mother's wedding i didn't even look
at him because his hair is down today i
was like ah
so um the girl first of all when she
first arrived they took her photo and
made her sign an nda
i went to the teen titan house and i did
that too so that's just for everybody i
think yeah but it's weird
it also means nothing if that happens to
you like i don't mean anything just
so originally she was like can i even
talk about this because like it's an
intimidation
here she is when she first made it take
a talk about it
oh she looks different here she says
signed to nda at a famous youtuber's
house
and then he essayed me
yeah no more fortnite 19 fortnight
who was crazy how tick tock is just
airing out all your trauma i've admitted
more stuff on tick tock than i've
admitted to like my therapist someone
was like okay this is a trend let's talk
about it
isn't that crazy i mean it's good like
it's healthy it's a good outlet like
that makes you feel safe but
i like to talk and she posted another
tick tock saying
um that
oh this is the same tech talk
oh you're right and i did make a full
youtube video explaining everything but
i'm talking to a reporter now instead
that contacted me because if everyone's
gonna hate on me for something
that happened to me might as well say it
louder for the people in the back
and maybe this will encourage some other
people to come forward about stuff that
happened to them
because if i don't stand up for myself
no one's gonna stand up for me
but i cannot put up my video until the
reporter does their report
and since i did sign an nda with the
youtuber prior to all of this happening
um the reporter has lawyers with their
company
and they're just going to look into
whatever wait i never saw an article
come out right she already put the video
yeah maybe they did yeah
oh yeah getting tagged so anyway um
she did put out a video and she
described the whole thing where she says
basically
they went up to the room and were making
out and kissing and then he
tried to get moving on to like you know
third or fourth base i guess i don't
know and she said she didn't want
to and then he told her well if you
don't want to then what's the point
okay so like we're like okay he's an
[ __ ] right that's what she says but
what happened next
was that okay i mean it's one thing to
be an [ __ ] and just be like okay well
then
you know leave but what he did later is
that she
he got up she was laying on the bed held
her face down
and uh f squared
f squared that's what they're called f
squared wait what does f squared mean
wait there's a there's an acronym for
that see so i think i just i left
me something else a lot of classified
something else is so crazy
that's what it means they're shorthand
for everything okay
terminology holy crap okay
she got anyway he assault he he he
basically those were her words by the
way that was white
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so he like
let's say how do i put this fellatio
fallaciously forced fellatio
non-consensual flavors non-consensual
fellatio
not funny but i'm laughing and jake's a
big guy like he's
cuz i saw two comments being like how
does that even happen what do you mean
how does that even happen like you have
a big guy that just like
and it lasts 30 seconds she said she
just he went
right on her face in like 20 30 seconds
just finished
and then left the room so it's like of
course like you don't even know how old
she is
you don't even know what's happened
before it's done like i see so many
people on the internet
trying to defend jake by saying like how
could that even happen it's like
you don't think it's 20 30 seconds i
mean it totally it totally sounds
plausible what's her name
justine paradise
it's probably not a real name oh here it
is she's 23. oh
yeah she looks so young like i was like
um
yeah 23. damn
so yeah people it's like literally
people are just like numb to this or
they're like yeah
i think there's a lot of rape apologists
who are just scared because they've done
[ __ ] like this and they're trying to
[ __ ] they're scared they're scared to
confront that they've done [ __ ] like
this and they want to
make it seem like what he did is fine
or impossible because they're trying to
rationalize to themselves
that they're not pieces of [ __ ] too
and um that's the only logical
explanation
and like her watching her video was just
like so sad she just looked so
she's just so nonchalant about it was
just like so sad like she just made it
seem like it was like and that's how
everyone's taking it like not a big deal
like no one it's not really like as big
of a story as it should be i agree
and i think just because he's coming
like he'll david dobrik and james
charles right then everyone's like oh
but like if you came out
and without those two stories would be a
huge deal
it's really sad i don't know i don't
really know the answer other than like
unless like
legal action is like you know someone
gets arrested or something it's like
doesn't really it's worth talking about
though that's what we're talking about
yeah for sure
just still people no yeah that's
awareness for sure
and but here here's i guess people a lot
of people have been calling her a cloud
chaser and [ __ ] i think also because
jake paul is known as like a piece of
garbage people are just like oh okay
you know what i mean i'd be surprised if
he wasn't right
right and it's really sad and she still
not okay
by the way that paul family is like
literally white trash like their dad
lived in a [ __ ] trailer outside jake
paul's mansion
and did you know that his dad greg ball
was like f was like screwing young girls
yeah and he had like a sex take leap and
like tricking they thought they were
kissing like a young guy it was him like
dude you can't make this [ __ ] up like
the whole they're just a family of
deeply disturbed creeps look up greg
paul dude the guy is
[ __ ] yeah such a goon i don't know
much about him i knew about that
under the swap swapping out him for like
a young guy
that's not oh the kissing bed yeah oh
but did you know that he had a leaked
sex tape with a young girl
greg paul you can't see her you could
just see him eating her out
it's really gross i mean i don't want to
shame him with sex tape but if she's
under age or something
she's young if they're under the age of
25 like no no jake paul doesn't hang out
with people
that old that old i would assume
if i would make a guess she was probably
like around 18. because this was like
years ago
that's so gross so i just understand
there's
well you can understand why the way they
are if that's their dad agb
coming at you anyway here she is because
everyone again
it's like even now after david and james
you still can't come forward
with all these legit receipts and
everything and still not be
totally [ __ ] on and accused of being a
clown chaser it's like look at all this
clout i'm gaining from
[ __ ] saying i was her essayed by jake
paul
i'm drowning in clout over here well
she has like a point like the more you
talk about maybe more people it's kind
of like the david effect right like all
of a sudden
everyone likes to blame it on me but
it's like one person says something and
then other people start feeling
comfortable and it's good it's good
because you know it does end up working
like
kind of the david think he had to
address this stuff because now more and
more people came out their story
and they go you know it's like because
now they're seeing okay
i'm you know especially with james now
people are seeing like oh people are
seeing him for a monster let me just
like
add to that verification it's not like
trying to bring someone down she's like
oh i also have the story to validate
what everyone else is saying
yeah i think it's important i think it's
more to keep saying and it's cool tic
tac is cool and youtube is cool to have
that if you have a story that's why i
always have send my stories people like
you're selling a broken record get over
it trish but like the more i said it
like the more people
you know came forward with theirs and
way worse than mine like the seth thing
everything everything after me i was
like holy [ __ ] like
it's kind of as a man
i'm kind of learning i mean i knew that
it was prevalent but i'm learning
and from reading and seeing all these
experiences it's it's
insane how prevalent
like essay is like it seems like most
like the vast majority of women in their
life
experience the being the victim of some
kind of
sexual violence every every woman i know
and i think back like 10 years ago you
knew what i think it was
like the stuff that is that you don't
you didn't think it was like
you thought if someone like tried to
kiss you and you didn't want you and you
said no like that was totally fine but
like that's literally
not or like even sex stuff like that if
you say oh i'm not feeling and they
still like go in for it it's like you
like it you don't realize it but now i'm
glad people are but every single girl
has definitely had it or someone they
know
it's just shocking to me because it's
like
well i just feel like we're not as a
society
like women are just their whole sexual
experience is so much different than
men's
and it's been kind of like either swept
under the rug or a secret or just
totally not like men as a whole as a
gender
have not had the amount of sympathy
or understanding of the female sexual
experience
yeah it's shocking to me now that my i
mean
just in the past like 10 years or so
with there's been a lot happening and
i've been reading a lot and it's just
like um
it's great i mean yeah i mean it's i i
can't believe that
i was like 90 seems like 95 percent of
women have been
some kind of victim of this [ __ ] in
their life like something or the other
and
i'm just it's just [ __ ] up i mean well
it's really cool to see this happen
it's probably like the metoo movement
for hollywood this is like it's like the
me too movement for just regular people
now that there's tick-tock and things go
viral and stuff like that like i think
that's really
a cool thing because now people can't
get away with it which before people
could
you know for whatever reason but now
they can't get away with it i think
that's right
it's good for young boys to learn about
what is and not okay because like
the bar is always kind of moved or
maybe it was something that wasn't
openly discussed but i feel like as a
society
it needs to be very clear to young men
like
oh what is and isn't okay
um that was always my issue with i think
david just never addressing anything i
was like address this because all your
fans think it's totally fine what they
did to seth what they did and i still
don't think seth got the justice he
deserved because he's a male and because
you know obviously uh hannah you know
came out too and a lot more attention
went to that but
uh the fact that he didn't address that
thing properly like that wasn't cool
either and like jason nobody had to
address that it's like
so these people all think that's totally
fine like they're boys like scott sire
being like boys will be boys that's what
we do we just [ __ ] with each other it's
like
no it's not okay like and the fact that
more people didn't like they didn't
touch on it david kind of did at the
apology at the end but that was like my
big i don't think he ever contacted
seth did he not i don't know he didn't i
don't think so i never heard about it
i'm still waiting for my phone call yeah
you never heard from him i mean you
never heard from him like you know at
the very least right he thinks okay
trish is going to talk about it on front
of me or whatever like that but at least
like try and make yourself look good at
least like apologize wait
yeah because he's like i'm reaching out
to everyone and he never called you
i guess he doesn't think he did anything
wrong with you literally i don't think
so
yeah i don't think so which is insane
it's crazy but it's fine
honestly like at least a little bit of
like
closure was given to like yeah i don't
think seth got close i don't think he
got the right amount i can ask seth if
he
ever heard from david or jason i mean he
was the one that did it too it's like
right or jason jason just been so quiet
i wonder if he sent him a heart like you
did you hey babe just wanted to talk
that's crazy hey babe
he basically said that dude didn't he he
was like hey babe heart
let's chat call me please
hey trish it's jason call me please red
heart anyway after getting
called a clout goblin by some [ __ ]
maniacs online this is what she said
someone called her that oh yeah she's
getting a ton of [ __ ] from people
god why why are people depending on
anyone for clout
um i've kept this to myself for a long
time
so making the decision to share it
publicly
is terrifying because i know i'm gonna
have a lot of attention
on it and and i know a lot of that
attention is gonna be hate
and i don't wanna deal with all the hate
that i'm gonna get for like something
bad that happened to me
but also i know it is necessary to share
this information with
everybody so it could maybe like save
someone
that would be in my position in the
future i haven't shared this
youtube video previously with all the
information in it because
like it's scary to share so i've been
kind of mentally prepping myself
and also some like big reporters said
it's in my best interest to wait and
since i've never shared anything like
this
and i assume they had more like
knowledge than me i decided to
like go with that but i think that's
wrong i think it's just in their best
interest for me to wait
hello i am what what
that is in the best interest of the
reporter to wait why is that because
because they don't she didn't want us
yeah they want to break the story um
they're like don't post till our story
comes out and she's like well what if
it's cat and cat just going on all these
shoes it's amazing she's good like i
like well that's good though that means
that
there is more coming for jake paul if
there's someone working on it but if you
do want to
i do recommend watching your video if
you can stomach it but it's just too
crappy
especially because she's so young so
it's just like a little it's a lot to
think about like
i don't know okay oh this is a re-upload
wait where's the original did you take
it down
no i think the guys just backed it up
just in case
but um i wanted to give hero fun
if you guys want to watch her original
video which i recommend if you can
stomach it
it's here and
it's called trigger warning and jake
paul seriously assaulted me
yeah and it is uh on just justine
paradise channel
so hi uh um
yeah it's a lot so
who does these lists for you they're so
organized it's like a little
we have a team yeah we do i mean like
who specifically one person has to write
all this down
ever it's a collaborative effort you
share this document yeah
everybody has access to it it's a
process that we've perfected over the
years yeah they need a raise there's so
much i feel like i'm looking at like a
dissertation
yeah i mean look we've been doing this
for a while and um
we do three shows a week so we have to
be organized
so we're working pretty good as a team
team unit
but oh you want to talk about the khloe
kardashian drama
are you tired what happened to you you
are so tired now i feel like
what did i do you're like here i feel
like you're about to fall asleep
well i did eat two extra large pizzas at
the very beginning i wanted it i wanted
to wait till the end but trisha was like
i have to have it hot or i'm gonna
i would never have done it from the end
khloe kardashian let's
talk about it you see her photo don't
show the photo because her lawyers will
copy right now
i was wondering if i should show the
photo real did they really copyright the
photo and taking it down over it that's
so weird
okay let me so if you guys didn't hear
khloe kardashian her nan
her like 90 year old nana took like a
candid photo of her and posted it on
instagram
and um and she looks norm like a normal
body in it not like a freak kardashian
body
no she her body is lipo for the gods
lipo oh is it she's had like liposuction
after life was like
you can tell you can tell that's a lipo
body for sure it does look a little odd
and she's had her butt down in and you
can see before photos now look at her
face now her face are you sure oh you're
not gonna
okay her face they can't see this but
okay right her face in this photo looks
like an old chloe face meaning like her
face when she was younger maybe like
five years ago she has a lot of work
done since
then and she photoshops a lot of it
whatever not not work um photoshop i
mean since then and so like it looks
like her old chloe face that she doesn't
want people to see anymore
and it's like that's what you look like
and she looks good and everyone was
saying it everyone was like wow she
looks so good
right i think it was more shocking
because that looks like an old chloe
face that we haven't seen throughout the
filter so everyone's like wow and she
looks so pretty she looks so much more
youthful and like glowing there
now she then posts like was like all the
people were like trying to get these
photos removed off the internet it's
still there i mean it's like easy to
find you can't ever get rid of this
you can't ever get rid of it she's and
then what but it was okay whatever
that's fine but then what pissed me off
and she did her reaction on her
instagram
she posted like a video of her like
flexing her super six back down yeah
she's just like
my body that i've worked hard for first
of all you've all lipoed it like you've
all lipoed your body here's the video or
i don't know if this is too graphic i
don't think so they'll tell us because
she's like
anyway but like i saw the real candid
can you mute then i saw the candid photo
of you i mean
and it's like you kind of look the same
like your face is i think that
my my thing was her face how different
she looked like she faced tunes a lot
and her face is hidden in this
video then go to the next one
she's showing this she's like okay look
at my body
like just trying she obviously screams
insecurity be trying to show people how
flat her stomach is
which again that's a it's a body by lipo
you can see before and after it's a body
and
yes you have to work hard to maintain
the lipo that's not like the thing but
it's like this would have been the
perfect moment to be like hey yeah we
set on realistic beauty standards that
even we can't achieve
yeah so that's what i wanted like that's
all you had to say this was like the
perfect time to be like
that's always been my why i dislike the
kardashians is because
dude there's they're ruining the
perception of a whole generation of
women
what they should like they're like the
leading cause of depression amongst like
teenage girls yeah and it's it's i think
if they were to say like kylie deny is
getting lip filler right and it's so
obvious when you look at pictures of her
like two years prior to her being
seventeen fifteen to seven
all of them have so much work so much
work you look at the before and after
like kim kardashian chloe had so much
work and it's like
and once i found that out that like
someone someone that works for them told
me oh yeah they get liposuction which i
had no idea as like a young girl i got
liposuction at 21. i was like that's all
you need and guess what my body changed
completely too it's like
if you're just honest about it i think
it's like a lot better but these girls
think that like they they have to
do all these squats to have a butt like
you when in reality just go to a doctor
like
have you seen like these photos of like
kim's butt like in the wild
yeah it just looks like it's crazy bro
anyway but it's their face too and it's
like you know you can't just say it's a
workout like you changed your whole face
and the i didn't even recognize that
that was chloe in that last video
in the right that doesn't follow on that
closely but i remember what she used to
look like i used to uh
i used to serve her all the time can i
show that yeah i worked at a restaurant
and she used to come in and she was
a fairly regular customer yeah she was
actually really sweet um
she was always really nice they seemed
nice but why are they so hell bent on
like
yeah well i think they're yeah they're
it's like
serious body image yeah she had a baby
she's close to 40 like it's not like
people are
can i show this i've just been wondering
like first of all from a
from a fair use standpoint i think i'm
good because like um
it's newsworthy i don't think it all
shows because it's
not a public photo that she doesn't want
out there so there's that aspect
i don't think i'll show it but you can
find it easily and everyone was saying
she looks great no one was like shaving
her
wow this is amazing you look like a real
person a real person and then like oh my
god get that take it down
exactly i i i it left a very bitter
taste in my mouth
they've been like super [ __ ] um
aggressive with the taking down of this
photo everywhere
aggressive like everyone has called me
the fastest or like i'm not allowed to
be insecure because i'm rich it's like
it's not about that it's just about
being honest
she said that i didn't even read it yeah
she had it in her instagram post she had
like a
paragraphs of stuff and it just being so
defensive and it's like oh here's her
be honest like it's just so not did you
guys like
literally people to
show your real body because that's like
the best thing you can do for
the health of people right now yeah or
she you know what she should have done
in this situation
she should have posted the photo herself
and be like yeah this is me
like i don't know like own it like it's
something hey guys this is me and my
body
unretouched and unfiltered the photo
that was posted this week is beautiful
but as someone who has so why are you
going after literally everybody who even
like
like everybody on youtube is scared to
show it like i was
when i was doing research for this i was
like has anyone on youtube shown the
photo
because i don't know if i should or not
mm-hmm and like phillyd
you showed it no he didn't nobody showed
it
so yeah so because they're because
they're afraid right but she's saying
it's beautiful
why don't you post it yeah she says this
photo is beautiful
but as someone who has struggled with
body image your whole life when someone
takes a photo
of you that isn't flattering in bad
lighting or doesn't capture your body
the way it is
after working so hard to get it to this
point and then shares it
but your your body looked fine yeah
bad lighting and even if it didn't like
everyone's telling you did no one's
coming for you and saying like wow
you're disgusting you let yourself go
how many like dude i'm sorry but you're
like the biggest public figure in the
world like people are always following
you and taking photos
yeah like well why this one is the one
that all of a sudden
oh i have to make this uh philosophical
stance unless it was all for publicity
and get people talking about her because
i mean it worked but i don't know like
it seems so odd i don't think in a good
way everyone's like
so she says you should have every right
to ask for it to not be shared
regardless of who you are
in truth the pressure constant ridicule
and judgment my entire life to be
perfect to me other standards of how
i should look has been too much to bear
chloe is the fat sister chloe is the
ugly sister
her dad uh must not be
her real dad because she looks so
different oh people think her dad is o.j
or some [ __ ]
i know there's like that one yeah no
that is
true the conspiracy it's not true
right hello twitter world
hello chloe um the only way she could
have lost that weight must have been
from surgery
that's what you said that's just what it
is should i go on being a personality
you're making yes she has more pages she
has
you make so much money like for people
talking about you like that's why you
guys are famous
like it's so weird this like double
contradiction like like who cares if
people say this about you that's your
fat sister
people say i'm fat all the time this is
what it is
i get what she's saying like like i get
it but i think she's using
i think don't say it's too much to bear
when you continue these shows for 12
000 seasons yeah you buried it just fine
you know what i do when i have an
unflattering photo did you see that one
i posted on my tic toc that moses
took me i posted it i looked like the
fattest i've ever looked in my life
right here let me turn down the volume i
think we'll ever top the post with the
video
look how huge i look why you're just
like a quaker
and i posted that i'm like 250 here dude
you look awesome
i look disgusting you look like quicker
oats guys and you know what i posted it
because i'm fat and disgusting at the
moment and that's what i'm going to live
in you know that's my body that's
nothing will ever
top the quaker oats are you talking
about quicker oats quicker oats
quicker oats oatmeal i don't is there a
mascot for opium
yeah he's like a quaker my face looks
like oatmeal or what i thought yes your
fa your thighs look like open what are
you talking about
wait quaker oats why why are they
oh i wrote quarter oats what's a quarter
oh why did they come to all that
oh it's like a location here that's you
uh you're quaker oats you're the quaker
oats guy
that's literally how you're dressed i
think so i had no hair in mine but yeah
i get i don't know
no maybe that hat i like more nothing
will ever
top the the photo of you as the um
god i gotta find that trisha paytas the
one that jason posted of you
and when you're at party how do you even
find it nfl or something maybe
nfl party let me just type in nfl
okay let me see if i can does it come up
oh it's like a sticker
[Laughter]
no he did originally but then i did
because i was like well
i mean that's an unflattering picture
chloe why are you wearing a do-rag and
like
athletic gloves he put me in that outfit
i don't know why could you imagine if i
went on an instagram and did my
photoshop picture and be like guys i'm
not
i don't look like that like nobody cares
yeah exactly nobody gives a [ __ ]
guys i have all body positivity except
for me where you laugh at my
quaker oats in my double chin
you presented it like i was supposed to
laugh at it what do you want me to cry
about you being fat every time you bring
it up
there's a tic tac trend where to get rid
of your double chin ready
you just put your tongue at the top of
your mouth
does it work are you sucking your tongue
okay
but it's not just the tongue because you
end up doing this
yeah i think it works it works on you it
works on you too
well i know it works but it but because
you can tell that you're struggling
like nah i am i look natural no you both
have like a bullfrog effect going on
we're like natural
yeah what are you talking about i don't
have a double chin i'm not fat
don't let the rest of my body go you
guys you guys look great
thank you anyways anyway look i i get it
but at the same time it's like
she went on like a four-page
dissertation about that she was like and
this and this and this
it's like your body is done it looks
good
your face you obviously use a [ __ ] ton
of filter and that's why i don't you
i've been using builder on all my
instagram photos go to my latest ones
they're all filtered
you're so honest about it though and by
the way i feel like these
these women owe it to the [ __ ] world
to be honest for once about what a
natural body
that is does that look like me no it
looks like you but it looks like you
know
filter like my nose is oh i'm on moses
instagram too so i always get his
comments
i would post a um i should post a photo
of me like that all over oh here you
should hear
do you have the pretty you don't have
the right filter though you have to like
download it out here
oh you can do it right now yeah
that's the filter you use yeah do you
have a cute face though
oh my god i look like 10 billion it
makes you all skinny
do you want my skin perfect yeah your
eyes model like you're actually being
serious
oh my god who is that do you agree with
that
people concerned okay wait let me take
another one okay let me try to look ugly
in this
oh my god this makes everyone look so
beautiful
okay well now it's not catching the
phone it even makes my eyes blue like
i'm sorry [ __ ] or my brown eye's not
good enough for you
let me try to look handsome so yeah yeah
i look like sexy
look at this dan just show it now look
at this why are you getting frustrated
huh you just did this who what
yeah this is great this is great content
mistakes well i'll just send you the
photo
okay i'll send in the thing what's up
all right frenemy's group chat is
getting a little full we have a lot of
people in the front of music group chat
but they don't even recognize them
what is that you slapped me with it was
the goo oh
people said we were off that episode i
know i didn't i didn't feel that way
really okay good because i felt
bad i was like was i off to you no no i
was like i don't know people are
tripping people look into everything
like so
deep i love the comments every episode
yep i'm out now this is the last episode
for me i always have
one of those yeah oh my god how do you
search
how do you search that comment out
because there's like the the response is
always like
overwhelmingly i just look for the
negative in like and then you find one
i have never seen a comment like that i
but you must dig like really deep anyway
let's let's talk [ __ ] that person let's
talk about chloe
chloe so we'll go on to the next thing
chloe oh
i already went to the next one says how
about who cares how i who but who
oh poor chloe who cares how she feel
because she grew up in the
life of privilege i can't read that far
so you have to stop
yeah she says but who cares how she
feels now she's in third person
she grew up in a life of privilege she's
also a reality so she signed up for all
this
i'm of course not asking for sympathy
but i am asking to be acknowledged for
being a human being yeah i mean but like
nothing bad happened to her it was like
a picture was posted there was not like
there's it's not like she got robbed
everyone's like poor rich girl like then
people would have sympathy like
obviously no one deserves to be robbed
but it's like
you said a photo like like people were
saying parents my mom posts the most
unflattering photos like go to my mom's
facebook it's under lana paytas
you're so beautiful yeah it's such a
good photo of you
it's some [ __ ] they have mom eyes
right but also it's just normal like
sometimes i do look fat and ugly and
sometimes i look beautiful and it's all
the same person
it's like that tic-tac-toe i respect you
a lot for that thank you
that you're willing to show all sides of
you i think that's very important i just
think it's i that's why i get really
upset about this now because i think
it's so dangerous for like people
i agree i i i absolutely i think they're
i think the kardashians are so [ __ ]
because of [ __ ] like this
you have to own this dude you have a
chance to actually help people like
feel okay about in their bodies well
that's what happened with anna nicole
she said trim spot she also that way and
there's another there was a miner that
like
died from it that's why they stopped
selling trump's box i had like a fudge
don't you remember she lost all that
weight and then she does commercials for
diet pills it's like trim spa babies
oh they're selling like meth right it
was like ephedra and yeah and it was
like crazy
yeah and so on i was taking as a kid
because you thought oh that's how she
lost 60 pounds like okay doesn't that
[ __ ] with your head like oh i'm sure it
did i'm sure it did i was so [ __ ] up
from it and i i did lose like a bunch of
weight but i think a couple people died
from it they were selling that on tv
in the store you could go to cvs like a
tart yeah
like she also did i mean you have to
work hard like if you get liposuction
it's like you just lose weight but
she did get help and if people don't say
it like people end up dying trying to
look like you like it's [ __ ] crazy
yeah because they used to peddle diet
pills they used to do quick slim
and so it's like you're you're just
promoting it's a good point it's a great
it's a great point and you can have lipo
and still be healthy you can like work
out i'm someone who had lipo and didn't
work out and not healthy so there's like
two different lipo people
those who continue to be a fat ass kim
kardashian she can't just walk around
like with this [ __ ]
ass the side of a the size of like a
locomotive
and like the time the tiniest waist and
like huge boobs
her body just looks like so freakish
like no body looks like that naturally
no you need to be honest about that
i know i don't understand why people
aren't either she says blah blah blah
she just keeps whining
shut up nobody cares it's so that's
literally what she said like literally
nobody gives a [ __ ] like nothing bad
happened to you it's like you said it's
like
okay i have empathy and yeti but it's
like nothing happened to your nana
posted a [ __ ] picture of you and like
get over it
yeah and everybody's insecure and
everyone deals with it and everyone
signs up for it that's just life you
know what i mean like i don't know what
else to say
i really want to show the photo no it's
not worth dealing with it
yeah i mean if she's like that
traumatized by but if that's the case
then she needs to get off reality team
and social media all together maybe just
see a therapist for a little while if
you're that traumatized by it like damn
girl you should look good
she sees her therapist at the same time
as a plastic surgeon
they meet together that'd be good and
convenient time saver exactly like
shampoo conditioner here
here's someone plastic surgery
consultant just to give you an idea of
what they're doing
on twitter they're locking accounts that
are posting the photo
wait what on what on twitter yeah on
twitter
oh my god like they are on an all-out
war like is that real
elites of attorneys sending out dmca's
oh my god there's literally people like
dying like and they're like let's take
this out like why don't you use that
lawyer to like
help like you know that's a line isn't
that a line from the kardashians that's
what you're just saying
oh yeah maybe while there is
for what they said courtney's the only
real one i would say courtney is the
only real one but then she also hang out
with us and ray which there's just a lot
courtney was the only real one she was
like i don't really care about all this
[ __ ]
but now she's like david dober and
edison ray she mentioned david dobrik on
kardashians last week
she's like really yeah she's like oh
david introduced me to addison
that's like 42. we're talking about them
on the show yeah is this show really
that popular i never watched i think
it's over now
why are they so popular honestly i don't
know i'm not even a hater i literally
don't know i don't know
i know it's like a meme or whatever but
like either was looking at that post
and she's like 150 million followers on
instagram and it was like
oh how is this possible i don't know i
literally i don't know
i'm genuinely i also i'm genuinely
curious i don't know if it's like their
fashion or
because i watch the show and it's just
not i mean i can buy entertainment
anything obviously i think
we should do a reality show i don't know
what it would be like what would it be
like the simple life what do the
kardashians do
you just want to do that just eat salads
and talk to each other that's what we do
here is that with the kardashians yeah
they just like eat salads and be like
there was one episode the only one i
remember is a conversation because it's
from tic-tac where they're eating salads
and they're planting a candy land
and courtney doesn't want to have any
sugar and she has but courtney it's
candy and shake there's candy without
sugar
but it's not candyland and then she
courtney's being so annoying right now
and that's like all they do is they talk
about that the whole time like that was
a whole plot line
this show sounds awesome we could
definitely up do that
we're like the kardashians except like
without makeup and filters and lawyers
and
and like and then like the uh we got
rolls royces
that's true that is true
we're like the jewish kardashians you're
not jewish
not yet i'm i'm i'm filtered and people
want me to
have a real talk with you about your
anti-semitic tendencies
do people really think that i'm
anti-semitic do you think i'm gonna say
that no
well i think you make a lot of
stereotype about jews i don't think
you're anti-semitic
i'm right but the stereotypes you make
about jews feed into anti-semitism but
it's my love for them
i love the stereotypes of jewish people
yeah but so the people that hate jews
believe the same stereotypes you do but
i
love that they're not real stereotypes
i'm trying to turn the negative
stereotypes into something positive
like jews control the world no i just
like like that jews are up
upper ep epchelon of society oh yeah so
that's like part of that
deep anti-semitic so what do i say
jews are trash what's the opposite of
this trash would probably be more
probably better i like the stereotypes
of like their noses i would like my
son to have moses's nose it looks so
nice it's nice and big and i like it
but in a good way i'm being so serious
yeah i mean that that is a deeply
anti-semitic trope
but i love the nose i do i love it
mine looks like a little rabbit a little
frog not a rabbit rabbits are cute mine
is a frog i don't think that there
really is a jewish nose
you don't have one exactly okay so like
that's an anti-semitic trope
have you seen like propaganda photos
from like nazi era
i get it i'm sorry okay i apologize for
real
if i offend someone actually i don't
think you're trying to be offensive so
i'm not trying to i know i love jewish
men so much like that's all i go for
i know but that's like i know what
you're saying but the same time like
that's my preference like they're so hot
that's fine to be attracted to them okay
if you like jewish guys that's so how do
i say that without coming across as
fetishizing
like between you and god when i was
single my bumble was like don't talk to
me if you're not jewish
but there's certain things that you say
that you should know as a stereotype
that leads
that is the knowledge the nose is the
stereotype the world domination
thing cheap but you kind of are me
yeah how am i cheap i don't know you're
actually not you bought a rolls royce
impulse bought a rolls royce
you're not cheap actually you're very
generous i take that back i feel like
i'm not cheap no you are passover you
like be like passing out checks to
everybody i didn't get checked but
well i gave it to all of our family
members oh my god i pay you every month
well i need to give you a five thousand
dollar check
i was like where's my check see that's
[ __ ] up that you come out and call me
too no
i resent that i just said i'd take it
back because you gave everybody money
for literally no reason on a holiday
that you're not even supposed to get
money i was like okay i want to be in
this family
i take it back you took back your
misogyny earlier in the episode i take
back that
idea people say we're growing that we
already apologize with the minutes of
knowing what we did was probably that
by the way that is a hurtful stereotype
the jews are cheap
okay i won't say that that is a very
anti-semitic and hurtful stereotype okay
done yeah especially because i try hard
you're not you're i know but i just
gotta have to explain how [ __ ] up
okay let me hear you because the
stereotype and i
i've always tried my best to to um
to to be as as uncheap as possible to be
as open-palmed
and generous as i possibly could be and
it's just it makes me feel bad that you
would come and call me cheap oh my god
first of all it was a joke but okay you
better keep in the whole thing about the
wrestling thing if you're keeping all
this in
i'm just trying to i feel like you're
going to edit that down because i can't
sometimes
you added some
the only time we ever edit is if
we don't when was the last time we
edited anything dan uh
i don't even i mean we've edited before
when youtube told us we needed to take
something
like when moses has like talked and
stuff like that it's edited out like if
he's like apologizing or something like
you edit out his apology one time it's
not a big deal i'm just saying like you
do
well yeah that was a different issue
i'm apologizing i think moses wanted me
to remove it
no he's like oh they edited that whole
thing out it was him like trying to say
sorry anyways it's not a big deal i'm
just saying i'm not editing it okay
cool you're trying to divert from you've
been a raging anti-semite
and i've apologized for my anti-semitism
okay i think when someone apologizes you
should be able to accept them if you
don't accept it's not a big deal you
don't have to accept my apology but i
apologize
i accept it you don't need a hammer at
home but i i can keep taking it i'll
keep listening i love educating myself
especially if my kids are going to be
jewish i need to be and not anti-jewish
definitely should understand they might
be anti themselves then they'll be like
oh i'm so confused
yeah that's not good moses told somebody
yeah i'm kind of christian jew i'm both
i'm a jew for jesus apparently
you guys were telling me that your
housekeeping
oh people always wonder why so i should
just explain it so people know because
people always took it for
30 seconds we have a review with youtube
so they say
okay um this podcast is
good to go and we won't demonetize you
or turn it mature
after you post it which is really good
yeah we need to know especially when we
put all this effort and we're here for
two hours
the problem is like if you say like one
wrong word like there's certain words
like let's say the c word you can't say
that yeah if you say the c
word once in a two-hour podcast they'll
mature the whole [ __ ] thing
yeah so like but they say okay we'll
review it ahead of time and approve it
but
you can't have it be over two hours
because that's just too much [ __ ]
work for us
sure and hit bye we can go over by a few
minutes which we are now
going to add a read so oh [ __ ] okay bye
see you next time so that that's why you
see us being like wrap it up at the end
thank you for my adam sandler phone case
you know who you are
what is this oh someone sent this to you
huh yeah who sent it to you just a
random fan you know i honestly
don't know it just showed up yeah thank
you my god
okay bye bye
you